[Music]
facebook
i'm robin from marshmallow laserfeast
we're a
experiential entity based in london
we're a creative studio exploring the
line between the virtual and the real
we take technologies like virtual
reality and
bring them to unexpected locations we
like to make
projects on the new digital frontier
that are exploring
emerging technologies and embedding them
into
live interactive immersive environments
[Music]
a colossal wave is about human impact
we were commissioned by the british
council and the category spectac
to work with the city of montreal to
celebrate their 375th birthday
375 years ago was when montreal was
founded it was also the birthday of
isaac newton
and we took his third law for every
action that's opposed
an equal reaction we started to talk
about the
contemporary issues facing all of us on
this this planet and
conversations about the great garbage
vortex cropped up
climate change we see burning forests we
see polluted seas but that goes
over people's heads and so we wanted to
communicate the ideas in in different
ways
we wanted to put creation in the hands
of the visitors
and what happens is there's an indoor
experience and an outdoor experience
both connected and the public are
invited
to engage in a mixed reality world
this world celebrates user-generated
artwork
indoor people sing and create voice
fruit sculptures
crack crack crack crack crack crack
crack
and these affect the outdoor experience
and outside what happens is a very
different physical artwork is created
a physical act of dropping a bowling
ball from a great height
and the bowling ball crashes against a
brass disc
a gong and sculpts over a thousand drops
the final gift that was given to the
city of montreal
what's exciting about the new advances
in technology such as virtual reality
is that there's new superpowers emerging
there's new ways to move
people and to engage people and we've
only just
really begun to understand the
grammar and the way that we can put
these experiences together
in ways that have a lasting impact on
people
what we've tried to do with this piece
is provide
a shared vr experience as well in this
case
people are connected they can see each
other in vr and
they get a sense of other activity
in the indoor space and outdoor space as
well
in different ways and we're only just
beginning to learn
how best to fine-tune this but one
thing's for sure
the sense of excitement that things like
virtual reality present to audiences
is just extraordinary we just can't wait
to see what's around the corner
it's it's moving so rapidly and
hopefully it'll
develop in a way that liberates us
and allows for more creative freedom
[Music]
you